it's a big day in Hollywood on one of
the biggest blocks here
uh sure is getting his star on the
Hollywood Walk of Fame it's real I got a
star now how big of a fan of us are you
guys huge look at midnight drove all
night to be here shaking I'm a big fan
of look see how he grabbed the mic like
that it was a big fan I'm ready ready I
am here supporting a friends yes someone
that I think has so many incredible
things about him that I admire this is
just the beginning and the best part of
the rest of his life you've been doing
this for a long time uh sure since you
were 14 what is reaching a mouse don't
like this meeting you it's big deal it
is these moments it's statues its
streets it's you know the signs that are
you know on the walls in an Egypt that
basically say that something happened
meaningful in that time how special is
it to share this moment with your son's
though so amazing man you know and
whatever they choose to do in their life
here is an obvious indication it there
is an incredible mountaintop that comes
to it when other people recognize you
that's good they say you do something
until someone celebrates you and when
they do hey hey you got it so I'm happy
for them to see it happy to celebrate
with my family have you given any
thought to how often you'll be here to
check up on this star man you're in a
prime location a man who knows what the
future holds but I do know that this
represents an incredible pass yeah and I
don't really want to take the
responsibility of keeping it nice and
shiny I'll do it man so do you do it
I'll do it man all right guys I told uh
sir I would come back and check in on a
star it's already dirty this will not
stand
who did this
don't mind me just cleaning us your star
watch it this is us your star watch it
this star is putting the other stars to
shame sorry Kate Smith yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah Rockaway that is one
clean star now it's time to keep watch
not let it happen again you a big fan I
am
you guys live around here no you come
over here for uh sure stars away from
Florida
no you did I'm serious no you did it I
got the roof of they know the story
yesterday's album a ticket and your aunt
this morning guys well here it is in all
its glory we are not worthy it's awful
ah this star is not getting dirty on my
watch yeah keep it moving you are in
front of uh sure star on the Walk of
Fame
uh sure I love uh sure
I love the man himself I love his
personality oh sure exemplifies
authenticity unique characteristics
undoubtedly one of the most
extraordinary musician I have ever seen
probably my top ten greatest you better
preach run
oh hello welcome to the et instacart
band give me your best red carpet post
go um are you a fan of Usher we don't
sound like Usher or Alesha but we try
all right uh sure I think I did a pretty
good job of keeping your star clean
unfortunately the streets a little too
treacherous for me so i'ma get up out of
this block and head back to mine later
hey guys thanks for watching ET on
youtube for more great videos be sure to
click to subscribe